xavier car on n'est pas un livreur à
vélo comme les autres cofondateurs de
l'association à deux roues il n'est pas
à travailleurs indépendants mais
salariés et ça change tout on souhaitait
remettre un peu d'éthique et de qualité
en proposant un service plus global avec
des conditions salariales classique le
smic mensuel 1500 euros brut
une couverture sociale le droit au
chômage avec le statut associatif les
coursiers sorte de la précarité
une démarche totalement approuvée par ce
restaurateur
j'ai participé activement à la création
de à deux roues parce que attend un peu
militant je refusais les modèles qu'on
nous proposait je ne citerai pas les
noms mais tout le monde connaît les
grandes plateformes qui à mon avis sont
pas très vertueuse la plateforme de
l'association fonctionne depuis une
semaine et déjà cinq restaurateurs sont
inscrits séduit aussi par la commission
prélevée au moins cher qu'ailleurs on va
dire quelle est la différence de tous
les autres supports de commande en ligne
c'est quelque chose qui reste locale
c'est quelque chose qui s'affiche sur
sur une éthique aussi quelque part
et puis pour aller dans le vif du sujet
c'est que en termes des commissions ça
n'a quand même rien à voir on va dire
qu'on a l'impression de travailler un
petit peu plus pour nous un petit peu
moins pour les autres à d'euros devrait
bientôt devenir une scop une société
coopérative et participative
d'autres ont vu le jour un peu partout
en france et à l'étranger grâce à un
logiciel libre coop cycle qui fédère des
coopératives de livreurs à vélo au début
de l'aventuré il ya quatre ans ça a
débuté avec une coopérative à bruxelles
et aujourd'hui on est une soixantaine de
coopérative en france en allemagne en
angleterre au canada et dans le monde
entier à deux roues emploie cinq livres
rares et espère pouvoir rapidement en
embaucher d'autres